in the fishing ports of northern france
they mainly docked disappointment
there wasn't much to land many had
forgotten the day's catch to protest
but they returned without resolution
we'll see he said dejected for now
determined to fight
many can't afford not to the new
restrictions could cut french time
fishing around the channel islands by
up to three quarters
his best
[Music]
it's not just livelihoods at stake here
locals say it's also a culture
under history french fleets have been
fishing off the coast of the channel
islands
for centuries it's a relationship that's
always been cordial and it's been
completely undermined
here feared the brexit trade deal they
insist these new measures weren't
discussed or agreed
and say the impact will be enormous i
would say
70 percent of the fleet it is dire
clearly if jersey government
don't want to change this position they
kill a part of the
french free trade fishing is a motive on
both sides of the channel
it's perhaps no surprise both sides are
digging in
it's a fight they say about principle
and pride
to secure a future that's fair
helen smith sky news in normandy